le microbiote on connaît celui qu'on a
dans le ventre
on connaît celui de la terre mais même
l'eau d'érable sont microbiote cet
ensemble de micro organismes jouent un
rôle primordial car il donne une partie
de son goût au sirop d'érable et pour
s'assurer de son bon équilibre certains
chercheurs se tournent désormais vers
des alliés minuscule
cet homme va injecter des microbes dans
de la sève d'érable directement à la
source
l'arbre il travaille pour le centre de
recherche acer à saint norbert
d'arthabaska
ici c'est l'érablière expérimental c'est
dans cette érablière là qu'on va faire
tous les tests le qui demandent des
installations particulières qu'on peut
pas reproduire chez les producteurs
beaucoup d'érable ici en deux ans taillé
à la fois ce qui permet de faire
certains tests mais le test
d'aujourd'hui est d'un type nouveau
microbiologiques pour lutter contre
certains microbes qui donnerait un
mauvais goût au sirop on en est gect
d'autres des microbes naturellement
présent dans l'eau d'érable et qui
contribue à créer la saveur du sirop
[Musique]
actuellement c'est sûr que c'est
exploratoire mais ça pourrait mener à
des nouvelles techniques de travail
il ya beaucoup de gens qui tentent de
contrôler les micro organismes
pour le dal système de production
l'approché innovante dans ce projet là
c'est de le faire dans la tubulure au
lieu d'essayer de le faire dans les
bassins de sel
[Musique]
la sève d'érable est un bon milieu de
croissance pour les bactéries les
levures et les moisissures
elles disparaissent bien sûr quand on
fait bouillir la selle mais elle
contribue à produire le goût du sirop
depuis qu'on utilise des tuyaux dans les
érablières la dynamique des microbes a
changé ils ne sont plus isolés dans des
seaux mais circule à travers tout le
réseau de tubulures la plupart des
acériculteurs nettoie chaque année leurs
tuyaux avec de l'alcool isopropylique
mais ça ne tue pas tous les microbes
pendant la saison des sucres
ils se multiplient et finissent par
recouvrir la surface interne des tuyaux
on appelle ça un biofilm le problème
c'est que certains de ces
micro-organismes transforment le sucre
naturel de l'érable le saccharose en
d'autres sucre qui caramélise trop vite
quand on les chauffe ses secrets là un
petit kart et vont faire des saveurs de
caramel intéressante à un grande
quantité valcourt plus avec des gouttes
brûler des caramels ocre très développé
et aussi savoir foncière beaucoup le
sirop d'érable pour éviter que les
mauvaises bactéries ne se reproduise
trop on leur envoie donc dès le début de
la saison des compétiteurs d'autres
micro-organismes désirable cela l'idée
c'est de voir est ce qu'on pourrait
s'assurer de contrôler ce qui va
s'implanter dans le système de tubulures
et ce qui va persister tout au long du
chemin du système de production
[Musique]
cette idée c'est le microbiologiste luc
lagacé qu'il l'a eu
il travaille au laboratoire du centre
acer à saint-hyacinthe ceux des
bactéries qu'on a isolé de la sève
d'érable comme pouvoir y en a une bonne
diversité le fait des études sur le
microbiote depuis quelques années l'on
s'est rendu compte que il ya une flore
microbienne un typique de la sève
d'érable et puis lorsque cette flore là
elle est où cette composition typique là
et peuvent favoriser ou qui auront on
déroge de ces profils là c'est là que
les problèmes peuvent se présenter
il a fait passer une série de tests aux
bactéries naturellement présentes dans
la sève pour savoir lesquels avaient le
plus de chances de coloniser la tubulure
il en a choisi trois celle qui l'a fait
d'injecter dans les tubes de l'érablière
de ces trois souches de bactéries une
semble prometteuse
on est tombé sur une souche tettey qui
était particulièrement performante que
c'est bien développés qui a réussi à
coloniser les systèmes et puis on a fait
tout le travail de suivi cette bactérie
lopssi on a produit des sirops également
le sirop et est sans défaut et a même
été jugée supérieure aux autres par les
évaluateurs de goût bref la technique de
l'udc lagacé semble avoir de l'avenir
un jour peut-être ces travaux
déboucheront sur un système pratique
microbiologiques pouvant être utilisés
par les agriculteurs eux-mêmes
ça pourrait déboucher sur un produit
commercial ferme à qui serait
typiquement d'origine acéricoles et que
les producteurs pour utiliser dans le
contrôle de la qualité de leurs produits
[Musique]